the graphs below show the test grades of
the student and of the students in
dexter's class
the first graph shows the relationship
between test grades and the amount of
time the student spent studying so this
is study time on this axis and this is
the test grade on this axis and the
second graph shows the relationship
between test grades and shoe size so
shoe size on this axis and then test
grade
choose the best description of the
relationship between the graphs so first
let's just before even looking at these
let's just look at these let's look at
the before looking at the at the
explanations let's let's look at the
actual graphs so this one on the left
right over here it looks like there's a
positive
a positive linear relationship right
over here i could almost fit a line that
would go just like that and it makes
sense that there would be that the more
time that you spend studying that the
better score that you would get now
there for a certain amount of time
studying some people might do better
than others but it does seem like
there's this relationship
here it doesn't seem like there's really
much of a relationship you see you see
the shoe sizes for a given shoe size
some people do not so well and some
people do very well for some some people
someone with a size 10 and a half it
looks like is that a yeah size 10 and a
half someone it looks like they flunk
the exam someone else looks like they
got a a minus or a b plus on the exam
and it really would be hard to somehow
fit a line here no matter no matter how
you draw a line it doesn't seem like it
would really fit some type of a
these dots don't seem to form a trend so
let's see which of these choices apply
there's a negative linear relationship
between study time and score now that's
not true it looks like there's a
positive a positive linear relationship
the more you study the better your score
would be a negative linear relationship
would trend downwards like that
there is a non-linear relationship
between study time and score and a
negative linear relationship between
shoe size and score well that doesn't
seem right either a non-linear
relationship you would it would not be
easy to fit a line to it and this one
seems like a line would be very
reasonable and there isn't any type of
it doesn't seem like there's any type of
relationship between shoe size and score
so i wouldn't pick this one either
there's a positive linear relationship
between studies time and score that's
right and no relationship between shoe
size and score well i'm going to go with
that one
both graphs show positive linear trends
of approximately equal strength no not
at all this one doesn't show a linear
relationship of really any strength